it looks like Warner Bros have sent me
something and it's not Dumbledore
so I've already unboxed it briefly we've
got a box here it says Hogwarts Legacy
portkey games
and on the top we've got
the art and making of Hogwarts Legacy
this book has all the little tidbits
behind the scenes how the game was made
all of the art that inspired the
characters everything really cool the
books also got tons of information on
characters that you may not know a lot
about
and they've also sent me four Hogwarts
house patches
Gryffindor Ravenclaw Hufflepuff
Slytherin
big thanks to Warner Brothers for
sending the care package we've been
loving the game